ciao sebbene rutino nuovissimo uomini
aprite le orecchie e arrivato il momento
di prendere nota una volta per tutte
perché queste sono le frasi che non ci
dovete mai dire e ve ne dovete ricordare
sai qual è il problema
se troppo perfetta secondo me è sì forse
ragione merito di meglio
merito di meglio di un cretino come te
che di giornate del genere si sa che nel
jazz di tutte le frasi che puoi dire per
scaricarmi cioè meriti di meglio è
proprio la peggiore schiera questa è chi
era quel tenero mi dicevo conosciuta il
quale serata si sta ormai non vi dirà
respira vino rosso vivo io non mi calore
tu mi devi delle spiegazioni è una
questione di rispetto
aspetta
[Musica]
e allora amore mio cucciolo se vuoi che
mi rilassi non me lo dire non mi dire
che vi devo rilassare che mi devo
calmarmi
perché ottenere solamente l'effetto
contrario ma non è finita qui perché
l'apice si raggiunge quando lui ti
guarda e ti dice facciamo una cosa poi
ne riparliamo quando di carta ok bravo
bravo ricky sempre discutere perché per
non te ne frega niente io sto male non
te ne frega niente è lasciato la tua
ragazza li incazzata da sola senza note
rito ma la cosa fantastica è che la
colpa per la tua bravo se molto
intelligente questi chiletti mangia
questi giorni cene feste cioccolato e
allora ormai è risaputo si sa che noi
donne siamo fissate con la linea e con
il peso ecco voi uomini non lo sapete a
quanto pare cosa non vi è chiaro che già
stiamo imparando ya e ci guardiamo allo
specchio e non ci piacciamo è l'ultima
cosa che vogliamo sentirci dire dal
nostro ragazzo al nostro compagno da
quello con cui usciamo e sei ingrassata
che cosa vi chiaro cosa non dichiarano
non ci potete dire no no no quindi come
fare ma non lo so non sai mai nulla mai
una volta che prende una decisione
[Musica]
io non perdo mai una decisione yo yo 200
dimmi una volta in cui hai preso tour
iniziativa una volta in cui hai scelto
tu ristorante aiuto più dove andare in
vacanza ho sempre fatto tutto io per una
volta che non mi va in mente niente
sentito ma perché innanzitutto su trucco
stai meglio senza e cioè con tutti i
soldi che spendono trucchi dopo aver
passato due ore per farmi questo make up
stratosferico chi come la frase del
genere rovini tutto noi donne ci
tocchiamo per per sentirci bene con noi
stesse per per piacere a noi noi a voi
cretini che neanche via indette conto se
uno è truccata bene se uno e struccata
se una c'è un bufala e dai che sfiga la
tua amica vedere non valeva la semi pure
nomi falsi pirla vedete in foto
interessanti schifani
senti cosa allora già mi dà fastidio che
seguì 400 fine su instagram sconosciute
se poi ci metti pure a fare
apprezzamenti su una delle mie migliori
amiche prima ruba non è più mia amica
amore guarda cosa come cosa medico si
vede no moto nullo e cioè ho appena
litigato col parrucchiere per più ore a
tagliare i capelli di 3 cm e io l'ho
detto che più di uno e mezzo non si
poteva fare e tu non lo noti come fare
una cosa d'accordo tutto telefono ecco
cosa nasconde nulla
questo telefono perché è una questione
di rispetto di privacy di fiducia dami
questo tele fiducia un parte di se
permetti e quando ce vo ce vo scusami eh
che poi l'ha detto mi fido di te cioè se
ti chiedo il telefono evidentemente
perché ho qualche dubbio se tu non me lo
dai
e quale sa che non mi devo fidarmi te
perché mi stai mettendo perché mi
nascondi qualcosa
siete tutte uguali tutte uguali quando
fai così lo sai che sembre sai che
sembri una mia ex
e allora mettiamo le cose in chiaro una
volta per tutte innanzitutto non sono io
con il comporto come lei ma è lei che si
comporta come me e poi che al mio di
come si comportava di cosa mangiava e di
come si pettinava la tua ex non gliene
frega niente a nessuno perché lo
sappiamo
amore questa sera guidolin e ama farlo
non la mia macchina ma perché no perché
assolutamente no la spiego brevemente
proprio allora voi donne
sapete cucinare sapete stirare sapete
come dire guidare è una cosa da uomini
miste chiavi subito ma vergognatevi
uomini anni anni di lotta per la parità
dei sessi ancora velocità con questi
luoghi comuni del cavo le donne non
sanno guidare le loro non sono
abbastanza forti appelli non sanguiniamo
una volta al mese non molliamo mai
noi portiamo al mondo la vita e voi
ancora che parlate guardate che il 2018
e noi donne siamo a un passo più avanti
eccoci giunti alla fine del video mi
sono divertita tantissimo a farlo perché
ha sfogato tutta la mia rabbia repressa
verso le 9 scherzi a parte mi raccomando
donne fatte vedere questo video tutti
gli uomi che conoscete xkè bisogno di
diffondere il verbo perché gli uomini
devono sapere una volta che le partite
se non vogliono far scoppiare del caso
caduta fatemi sapere con un bel
commentino qua sotto quale di queste
frasi è quella proprio che odiate di
quella che proprio non vi devono dire vi
fa uscire fuori di testa
se non l'avete ancora fatto iscrivetevi
al canale e attivate la campanella che
trovate vicino al cast di iscrizione ma
soprattutto seguite vissuto tutti gli
altri social facebook
instagram musicali vi mando un bacione e
spero tanto che dite